tous
[Musique]
bonjour angèle un jour vous êtes devenu
l'idole d'une génération en très peu de
temps votre premier album brûlé sorti en
octobre dernier
et puis connaît déjà un immense succès
vous serez bientôt en tournée dans toute
la france pour une musique à la
frontière de l'électro du hip hop et de
la chanson que moi j'adore les est que
vous êtes l'idole d'une génération jeune
et pourtant vous choisissez dans la
séquence du spectateur
un film qui a plus de 40 ans oui c'est
vrai il a plus du double de mon âge
c'est le sauvage c'est ma mère qui m'a
qu'il a montré énormément de films mais
plutôt anciens d'où le sauvage c'est un
fauteuil qui me l'avait qui me l'avait
montré celle qui m'avait acheté le dvd
à l'époque le sauvage jean paul
rappeneau avec catherine deneuve et yves
montand nommé quatre fois aux césars
même s'ils n'ont remporté aucun malgré
son grand succès public
plus précisément c'est donc l'histoire
de martin coutances incarné par yves
montand car un grand créateur de parfums
qui en a eu marre de la mondanités
parisiennes new yorkaise qui s'est
échappé sur son île déserte
et c'est là qu'une femme volcanique va
venir bouleverser toute sa petite
tranquillité et changer son quotidien
c'est presque une allégorie face et être
être coincé sur une île déserte
ça peut aussi résumé ce que c'est que
vous faites une histoire d'amour il ya
un truc très absurde la dame pour moi
c'est une histoire de d'un couple et de
ce que ça peut discuter voire comme
électrique entre en train de mener une
femme oui mais ce que montre le film
c'est que l'île déserte rêver d'amour
comme ça où on est en fusion dans le
désir et ça ne peut pas durer
salle île déserte explose tout part en
fumée cette image de de l'île déserte en
fait c'est carrément angoissant enfin
moi je suis un amoureux j'adore passer
du temps avec lui même et me retrouver
sur une île déserte avec lui je pense
que ce serait l'enfer et d'ailleurs on
s'est rendu compte que mes parties en
vacances dans un lieu qui ressemblait
d'ailleurs un peu au contexte du sommeil
ça que ça m'a fait rire dans une maison
un peu du style est en fait c'est
honnête de se disputer même là bas j'y
mets mais c'est la fin du monde
même ici on se disputait en fait on
s'est rendu compte qu'en fait les
problèmes ils nous suivent donc une île
déserte c'est le pire la séquence que
vous avez choisi angèle c'est drôle
c'est pas la séquence la plus iconique
du film c'est quelque chose de très
charmant nelly et martin se sont
engueulés querellés battu assommé
pendant tout le film
il se retrouve comme un vieux couple de
30 ans qui aurait pas grand chose à se
dire on la regarde
c'est parti allez
[Musique]
ces accords n'ont jamais du temps parce
qu'avec ma grippe
vous avez vu la grille oui la semaine
bien dire mais c'est fini maintenant
vous débattre à fait ça moi je suis
passé vous voir mercredi vous n'étiez
pas là
à quelle heure voire les quatre ou cinq
heures c'était marée basse c'est aller
pêcher dans les cailloux là bas de
l'autre côté a pas besoin de trouver un
bouteille et vettel l'élu saint georges
qui avait laissé sur la table
ah oui oui merci bon alors on perd quand
je ne sais pas quand on veut et bien
maintenant pourquoi pas je mets
d'affaires à l'interdît attendait il
faut quand même pas bien mais je veux
dire une fois cinq minutes on peut
surfer un peu quand même
bon bah alors si vous voulez peter dans
le calcaire au revoir non mais attendez
voulait pas monter voir un petit nom
alors ben laden et le style quand même
qu'ils ont tous les deux et c'est
surtout dialogue en fait où en effet il
se retrouve un peu comme un vieux couple
qui s'est vite ils vivent chacun leur
vie mais elles donnent l'air d'être très
très occupés alors quel pack ans
s'affaire sur une île déserte et cette
fameuse phrase à elle dès 21h45 et puis
mais pourquoi - car au quai victor fait
et puis ça plus évidemment la beauté du
paysage
j'aimais bien ce que je la trouve assez
subtil en fait et ça m'avait fait rire
le film appartient à ce qu'on appelle la
screwball comedy
c'est à dire une sorte de débit
ininterrompue où il se passe plein de
choses absurdes menée par un personnage
qui est une énergie débordante
en l'occurrence catherine deneuve et moi
ce qui m'étonne c'est que tout le monde
tous les mecs soient amoureux d'elle
alors qu'elle est quand même assez
insupportable elle est sublime halle est
belle mais elle est aussi assez
crispante énervante parfois vous trouvez
pas mais c'est ce qui m'a fait réfléchir
quand je les ai vus plus récemment vous
a frappé
ouais complètement mais même dès le
début le rôle qu'elle a au début qui est
un peu ce rôle de belle en fait le
prince aux caps de belle femme gâtée
mais c'est très ironique donc en fait il
ya pas mal il ya beaucoup d'humour et
c'est vrai que le personnage qu'elle
incarne j'arrive même pas moi même à
savoir si je l'apprécié ou pas votre
truc c'est un bon choix il montant comme
partenaire des catherine je trouve
formidable je le trouvais beau tu le
trouve extrêmement beau et je le trouve
en fait je trouve que autant l on a du
mal à l'apprécier mais on ne peut pas
décrocher les yeux parce que elle a une
manière de parler tellement drôle et
tellement absurde et est tellement belle
évidemment aux temps anciens et les
sympathiques dès le début et on a envie
de lui faire un câlin quoi enfin il est
il est tout de suite
il incarne tout de suite quelque chose
de rassurant et il ya aussi quelque
chose que je me rendais compte c'était
que il incarne vraiment la vérité je
trouve et incarne vraiment la féminité
les dialogues sont
sont signés jean loup dabadie sont
celles qui vont à toute vitesse capable
vous angel d'être une chipie d'être
juste énervante pour être énervante avec
un garçon j'ai eu un grand frère donc
oui j'ai un bel entraînement après j'ai
appris à développer une certain taux de
crie une voix assez perçante quittais ma
seule défense avec mes ongles en gel
merci beaucoup merci pour pouvoir voir
en concert avant que vous d'écoliers sur
votre île déserte
et puis si vous partez revenu s'il vous
plaît merci beaucoup à bientôt à bientôt
[Musique]